[Musique]
de là
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous écoutez
scopeo l'observatoire politique je suis
pire vitaly cofondateur de scopeo et je
vous souhaite la bienvenue sur notre
chaîne aujourd'hui nous sommes très
heureux de commencer notre série
d'entrevues politique avec monsieur
alexis poulain je laisse maintenant la
parole à lucas da silva également
co-fondateur de scopeo pour qu'il pose
le décor de ce podcast
et oui je te remercie pierre bonjour à
ceux qui nous écoutent et surtout
bonjour à vous monsieur poulin bonjour
nous fait l'honneur aujourd'hui de nous
accorder cette entrevue afin de discuter
et de débattre sur un sujet brûlant
d'actualité et donc nous allons aborder
ce thème qui et qui fait actuellement la
une de tous les médias
c'est cette dérive autoritaire du
gouvernement que de plus en plus
d'observateurs dénonce au quotidien de
tous bords politiques
mais avant toute chose avant de rentrer
dans le fond du débat monsieur poulin je
vous laisse vous présenter brièvement
pour ceux qui nous écoutent oui alexis
poulain je suis co fondateur du média le
monde moderne journaliste éditorialiste
pour rt france mais aussi sur sud radio
et on a vu aussi sur d'autres médias et
ge avance a aussi une carrière dans la
communication et la diplomatie très bien
je vous remercie
alors justement je vais rebondir sur
votre fonction première sur votre
origine vous êtes vous mêmes
journalistes et nous devons commencer
cette discussion sur la question qui me
semble le plus d'actualité est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment quelque part que
le gouvernement s'attaque à la liberté
de la presse avec cette désormais
fameuse loi sécurité globale quel est
votre point de vue alors selon
gouvernement non ils défendent toutes
les libertés compris celle de la presse
mais quand on commence à vouloir toucher
une loi aussi fondamental pour le cadre
de la démocratie libérale que la loi de
1881 sur la liberté de la presse et la
liberté d'expression en général ça pose
question et c'est grave parce que la loi
de sécurité globale c'est une loi de
circonstance c'est une loi qui est là
pour draguer un certain électorat pour
répondre à des attentes de syndicats
policiers mais c'est certainement pas
une loi qui va cadrer qui va faire date
dans l'histoire de la république
française
ou alors si elle fait date c'est pour un
fiasco justement dans la façon dont elle
est extrêmement mal rédigée extrêmement
dangereuse pour les libertés y compris
la liberté de la presse parce que
aujourd'hui les lois le cadre du droit
existe pour punir les usages de d'image
de policiers sur les réseaux sociaux une
cet article 24 était inutile et la loi
de sécurité globale qui souhaitent
encadrer une surveillance totale en fait
c'est la voix de surveillance globale
avec l' usage massif de drones avec
lusage d'algorithmes prédictifs
c'est le pire des mondes c'est la chine
qui débarque à paris finalement tout ça
en fanfare en disant que c'est pour le
bien être des concitoyens donc moi je je
je vois le danger immédiat de cette loi
de circonstances extrêmement mal fait
extrêmement dangereuses pour nos
libertés et je vois aussi tout l'agenda
de censure qui est mis en place depuis
2010 cette part emmanuel macron à la
fois pour éloigner les médias éviter
qu'il y ait un contrechamp on a vu la
façon dont il a traité la presse avec
unique ans certains journalistes
accrédités lors de voyages officiels et
qu'ils étaient des journalistes qui
viennent de chez me marchand et donc de
la presse people la façon dont il a
voulu aussi vidé la salle de presse de
l'elysée est là mais de l'autre côté de
la rue ça ne s'est pas fait quand même
et puis le rapport particulier qu'il a
la presse puisqu'il ne donne quasiment
jamais de conférence de presse
uniquement des interviews ou bien des
grandes annonces à la nation donc il y à
une pratique du pouvoir à ces
paranoïaques mise à vis de la presse et
où la censure pointe systématiquement le
bout de son nez
et quand ce n'est pas sur les médias
c'est sur les autres moyens de
communication et notamment les réseaux
sociaux
on se rappelle de la loi via première
mouture qui a été entièrement censurée
par le conseil constitutionnel parce
qu'elle était anticonstitutionnelle et
on voit on voit bien que avec cette
crise sanitaire revient par la fenêtre
cette joie via pour recommencer trouver
un moyen de alors sur ses pour lutter
contre les discours de haine
officiellement la vraie raison c'est
installer une censure sur les réseaux
sociaux et tout ça aussi
au niveau européen avec un groupe de
travail qui travaille sur les faits que
news dont nathalie l'oiseau par exemple
est membre pour organiser cette censure
des mains dans la main entre
gouvernement et gars femmes pour éviter
que la parole soit libre pour éviter
qu'on est une démocratie vivante donc
moi je suis contre tout ce qui peut
atteindre nos libertés tout ce qu'il
faut les réduire
et aujourd'hui je vois une majorité
dangereuses pour nos libertés
merci monsieur poulin peut-être pour
pour expliquer la loi sécurité globale
que vous dénoncez elle comprend
également l'instauration certes de cette
fameux article 24 est également le fait
d'équipés la police de drones mais cette
fois sécurité globale permet aussi
d'équipés par exemple pas la ville de
paris d'une force de police municipale
elle permet également la création d'un
observatoire de la sécurité privée pour
contrôler les renforcer le contrôle sur
la sécurité privée qui devrait amener à
se développer notamment dans le cadre
des jeux olympiques de 2024 et donc
finalement est-ce que vous rejetez cette
fois sécurité globale dans son tout avec
l'article 24 comme comme moteur du rejet
ou est ce que vous y voyez quand même
des avancées alors il ya certaines
avancées évidemment notamment sur les
moyens alloués à la police municipale le
fait qu'elles pourraient avoir accès au
fichier de la grande délinquance faut
aller plus vite plutôt que de devoir
référer à un officier de police ou à la
gendarmerie et donc ça c'est une bonne
chose
en revanche tout ce qui est le
l'encadrement de la continuité de la de
cadre sécuritaire en fait pour englober
davantage de sécurité privée dans le
maintien de l'ordre
c'est extrêmement angoissant parce que
ça voudrait dire qu'on aurait petit à
petit des milices privées qui feraient
la loi au sein des gares au sein des
centres commerciaux dans l'espace public
finalement on déléguerait une partie du
travail alloués à la police à des agents
de sécurité privés sans aucun contrôle
ou très peu avec le danger de voir se
créer de réelles milices donc encore une
fois c'est le manque de
de vision à moyen et à long terme des
législateurs qui moi me pose question et
puis on voit bien que derrière ils
pointent aussi le bout du nez d'un d'un
nouveau marché celui de la sécurité
privée donc ce serait formidable d'avoir
ce marché là est d'ailleurs jean-michel
fauvergue qui est à la manoeuvre sur
cette voie ne s'est pas trompé puisqu'il
a une société de formation conseil qu'il
a créée avant avant d'être député pour
former les cadres de sécurité encore une
fois on pourrait presque parler de
conflits d'intérêts tant il y en a
beaucoup dans cette majorité
la république en marche et donc on voit
bien que tout devrait être soumis aux
lois du marché y compris ce qui est du
domaine du régalien
c'est à dire la justice police la police
en l'occurrence c'est ce que fait jean
michel blanquer dans l'éducation il
essaie de casser l'éducation pour ouvrir
le marché des locations au secteur privé
est bien même dans la sécurité sous
couvert de cette loi de sécurité globale
à une des choses qui n'est pas mise en
avant mais qui est réel c'est cette
ouverture du marché de la sécurité à aux
acteurs du privé avec le danger que je
gêne on sait à l'instant de potentiel
milices privées financées par les plus
offrants
et ça c'était encore une fois
inacceptable dans une république qui a
pour devise liberté égalité fraternité
d'accord monsieur poulin et est-ce que
j'ai vous avez évoqué la loi via qui a
été retoquée par le conseil
constitutionnel
est-ce que vous pensez que justement que
cette loi que c'est que c'est politique
menée par le gouvernement
elles nous font sortir progressivement
un terme de l'état de droit
ou est ce qu'elles nous font rapprocher
des gouvernements qu'on aime regarder
d'un mauvais oeil du côté de la hongrie
du côté de la pologne
est ce que le conseil constitionnel
apparaît comme un dernier rempart à
l'état de droit en france
aujourd'hui oui conseil d'état conseil
constitutionnel et dans une certaine
mesure la justice dernier contre pouvoir
encore efficace quand on voit le peu de
d'état
qui est fait de la vie parlementaire la
pratique des manades la cre on a poussé
la vème république les institutions de
la vème république dans une caricature
total avec une boursouflure exécutive où
finalement le parlement n'est qu'une
chambre d'enregistrement et il ya un
poids mort bien emmerdant excusez moi du
terme
on l'a vu avec cet article 24
immédiatement plutôt que de faire
confiance à la navette parlementaire
l'idée était d'avoir une commission un
comité théodule annoncé par jean castex
pour réécrire l'article vite fait entre
entre copains et plutôt que de faire
confiance aux parlementaires tellement
l'exécutif n'en a rien à faire de ce
parlement donc il ya un problème
institutionnel en france évidemment
c'est le fait qu'arnaud mais autant de
pouvoirs sans contre pouvoir efficient
efficace la presse devrait être un
contre-pouvoir mais depuis la loi des
années 90 qui a permis aux industriels
d'investir massivement dans les médias
neuf oligarques milliardaires détiennent
quasiment 90% des médias français donc
on voit bien qu'il n'ya pas là de presse
indépendante a qui ont un poids
d'audience nécessaires pour être
rééquilibrée vous avez les instituts de
sondage aussi qui crée une réalité
alternative systématique ou chaque
week-end vous avez des sondages qui
l'encensent emmanuel macron où les
ministres en disant personnalité
préférée des français etc et qui font
oublier la réalité de la de assez
navrante de ce personnel politique qui
finalement fait beaucoup de
communication très peu de politique donc
aujourd'hui oui conseil constitutionnel
et justice c'est important nous les
avons parce qu'il ya une dérive libérale
bien sûr des modèles macron dans sa
pratique du pouvoir parce que finalement
tout le monde rêverait da d'être un peu
poutine en son pays de pouvoir avoir une
grande démocratie mais où tout marche où
il n'y a pas d'opposition ou très peu et
et où tout va filer doux parce que c'est
le pouvoir qui est élu une fois tous les
cinq ans et ça suffit c'est ça la
démocratie
non la démocratie c'est un débat
permanent au sein des assemblées c'est
aussi la question du mandat aujourd'hui
qui n'est pas révocatoire du mandat qui
n'est pas impératif c'est tout les la
question des institutions elle est
extrêmement importante si on veut éviter
cette dérive parce que
de la 5e et d'ailleurs françois
mitterrand la critiquer comme étant un
coup d'état permanent et une fois élu il
n'a rien fait pour la changer
ensuite on est passé du septennat au
quinquennat on a raboté davantage c'est
le travail qui avait été fait par de
gaulle et debré pour la constitution de
la vème et on arrive à un régime
totalement inefficace totalement
caricatural ou voilà vous avez des
présidents élus pour cinq ans qui font
même pas de mandat avec un parlement aux
ordres qui ne sert à rien et une
opposition qui est dans la rue puisque
finalement il n'y a plus de
contre-pouvoirs il n'y a plus
d'opposition
donc il faut changer ça parce que sinon
ça veut dire que l'on quitte
effectivement les rives de la démocratie
et qu'on rentre dans une autocratie rêvé
par certains puisque c'est la
privatisation des institutions par une
caste de pouvoir toujours les mêmes les
hauts fonctionnaires les énarques et
j'en passe et l'argent donc plutôt
cratie plutôt de démocratie et il est
important si on veut rééquilibrer les
pouvoirs bien de réécrire la façon dont
ces pouvoir se contrôler eux-mêmes et
s'auto contrôler pour éviter la dérive
actuelle qu'on a avec emmanuel macron
alors juste
vous parlez de la démocratie et du fait
que que nous nous en éloigne n'aurions
peut-être petit à petit cependant on
voit bien là sondage après sondage un
besoin de l'opinion publique et une
demande du peuple français
de plus d'autorité de plus de d'ordre
quelque part on dit souvent que le
premier parti en français le parti de
l'ordre et vous évoquez également la
question de la justice comme garant de
l'état de droit
cependant c'est cette même justice qui
est remis en cause par de nombreuses
personnes comme peut-être trop laxiste
et poussant justement à ses lois comme
la loi sécurité globale notamment par
exemple sur le cas des casseurs puisque
c'est justement à cette justice qu'on
reproche le fait de ne pas êtres assez
ferme contre ceux qui cassent et contre
ceux qui abîment les manifestations
quelque part et donc cela expliquerait
le ce retour en force de loi comme la
sécurité globale comme l'article 24 mai
comme peut-être la politique globale du
gouvernement pour réaffirmer l'ordre
comme comme besoin demandé par des
français alors il faut se méfier parce
que il ya la sécurité demandées par tous
les français qui est nécessaire et elle
n'est pas assurée on leur quartier
aujourd'hui on a enfin c'était quand
même cocasse lors du confinement de voir
un préfet très content d'avoir mis des
amendes pour non respect du port du
masque à un point de lille parce que les
gens venaient acheter leur drogue au
point dit là on est où
donc il ya un laisser faire
volontaire parce qu'on connaît les
situations inflammable et que la police
manque de moyens ça c'est un fait la
police manque de moyens et donc ne fait
pas son travail dans de nombreux cas par
on a vu on n'en parle pas assez
mais c'est vrai que la situation des
policiers qui interviennent qui se font
caillasser avec les pompiers etc en
embuscade
c'est intolérable et pourtant ça
continue ça a perduré et un effet pour
que ça cesse
alors on peut montrer les casseurs du
doigt on peut dire qu'il ya des
problèmes de manifestations encore une
fois qu'est ce qui fait qu'on a des
manifestations qu'est ce qui fait qu'on
a autant de gens dans la rue qu'est ce
qui fait qu'on sent aussi peu en
sécurité parce que la sécurité c'est pas
une question uniquement de sécurité
physique c'est aussi avoir une certaine
sérénité dans la tête sur le long terme
sur la pérennité de l'emploi sur
l'avenir de ses enfants sur la retraite
or emmanuel macron rend tous et à venir
ce traitement un certain pouvoir
extrêmement sombre alors à dire c'est
pas de son fait il ya aussi le corps
d'un virus il ya plein de choses mais il
faut voir que sa politique elle est là
pour faire en sorte qu'il y ait de moins
en moins de droits sociaux que
l'héritage du cener le conseil national
de la résistance soient liquidés pas à
pas pour laisser encore une fois place
au marché place à l'argent typiquement
faire de la dette étudiante là où les
états unis voudraient l'annuler cette
dette étudiante parce qu'elle devient un
fardeau pour l'économie pour la vie
réelle l'économie réelle donc il faut
arrêter à un moment avec ses c'est
politique qui ne sont qu'un personnel
finalement issus des banques d'affaires
et qui est là pour faire le relais de la
finance internationale et kinois d'un
pic que pense finalement d'un pays comme
la france et qui ne défend pas les
intérêts de concitoyens et qui ne fait
pas des politiques pour protéger pour
assurer la sécurité des citoyens donc
organiser le désordre c'est d'abord ce
que fait ce que font ses politiques avec
des lois extrêmement dangereuse pour la
cohésion sociale et derrière taper sur
les mécontents c'est ce qu'ils appellent
l'ordre non c'est davantage de chaos
davantage de violence donc la violence
elle est en cravate avant d'être dans la
rue et c'est cette violence en cravate
qu on ne dénonce pas assez que que
jaurès dénoncé que hugo dénonçait elle
est un visibiliser finalement comme
étant normal il faut réformer ce pays un
peu ringard qu'est la france les
français qui sont des gaulois
réfractaires qui comprennent rien et c
est cette violence-là deux de ses élus
en cravate qui se pensent d'ailleurs au
dessus des mois puisque les
contre-pouvoirs sont extrêmement faibles
cette violence là elle est celle qui
crée l'insécurité réelle et de long
terme et je ne minimise pas l'insécurité
après du chef de la délinquance et de la
criminalité mais celle ci est là elle
reste quand même assez stable année
après année même si elle explose en ce
moment puisqu'il ya eu mais confinement
puisque l'économie va mal donc la
criminalité augmente mais là encore
manque de moyens dans la police c'est
exactement comme pour l'hôpital c'est à
dire qu'on va dire que c'est pas un
problème de moyens c'est un problème
d'organisation non c'est un problème de
nombre de personnes qui peuvent faire
régner l'ordre qui peut assurer que les
français sont en sécurité
et c'est pas en continuant à mettre les
gens dans la rue à les précariser
affaire que
l'emploi ne paye pas qu'on va faire
diminuer la criminalité qu'on va faire
baisser l'insécurité
bien au contraire donc cette vision plus
globale elle manque systématiquement et
la dénonciation de la violence des
dirigeants elle manque aussi les
politiques néolibérales appelons-les
telles qu'elles sont faites aujourd'hui
on se retrouve après avait à prendre un
pays en exemple comme les états unis qui
est un pays qui était au bord du gouffre
lors de la sphère georges pologne où les
gens travaillent sont travailleurs
pauvres avec plusieurs métiers où on
voit bien que là c'est pas souhaitable
quand on a eu une sécurité quand on a
une sécurité sociale quand on a eu le
cnr quand on a réussi à mettre en place
une solidarité nationale qui fonctionne
parce qu'il faut rappeler que la dette
sociale n'en est pas une
on la joue maintenant sur les marchés
mais on pourrait tout à fait la combler
avec une politique fiscale juste
or ce n'est pas du tout la voix qui est
prise depuis des années un peu importe
la couleur du président qui est mis à la
place du prédécesseur etc
on continue à faire de l'europe à faire
la finance internationale à faire de la
dette et à casser les les droits sociaux
je crois qu'il est là le problème
fondamental c'est ce cette insécurité là
plutôt que l'insécurité de la rue même
si encore une fois je te la vie n'est ce
pas elle est réelle mais alors donnons
les moyens la police est pas et pas
seulement des drones nom des gens formés
qui vont pouvoir aller d ordonner une
police de proximité et là on parlera de
sécurité réelle je vais rebondir ce que
ce que vous dites parce que là dans
votre propos vous dénoncez quelque part
la violence d'état en fait finalement la
violence qui émanerait du pouls des
pouvoirs publics et on a quand même vu
il ya deux ans on oublie un petit peu à
cause de la crise sanitaire qu'on
traverse on a eu ce mouvement historique
des gilets jaunes
on n'a pas eu de mouvement social aussi
fort aussi contestataires depuis mai 68
et est ce que pour vous ce mouvement
social ils avaient l'air bon évidemment
ils révélaient déjà une grande fracture
dans la société française mais ce qui
constitue une sorte de rupture dans dans
l'autoritarisme que vous dénoncez du
gouvernement je pense notamment à
emmanuel todd qui évoquait vraiment une
une rupture dans la méthode
de la police en méthodes qui sont donnés
pour faire régner l'ordre et pour
justement que les manifestations ne soit
pas pacifique
est-ce que vous pensez que ce mouvement
social des jaunes a constitué une
rupture
oui parce que pour une fois les
locataires de passage dans les palais
dorés de la république ont eu peur c'est
eux qui ont eu peur pour leur sécurité
quand il ya eu la prise de l'arc de
triomphe les premières manifestations
le flottement au bord de l'elysée ils
ont compris que finalement il suffisait
de quelques dizaines de milliers de
personnes de plus et là on aurait eu une
scène peut-être comme le fenwick dans le
ministère de benjamin griveaux mai à
l'elysée donc ils ont eu peur et on voit
les vidéos des mines déconfites
d'edouard philippe avec christophe
castaner qui a l'air d'un chien battu au
pc de commandement qui sont comme ça
après l'arrivée de triomphe et la
réponse a été comme ils ont été blessées
dans leur dans leur orgueil
la réponse a été une violence sans nom
et oui là la façon dont les
manifestations de gilet jaune ont été
traités on peut parler d'une répression
d'état on peut parler d'une terreur
d'état parce que ce n'est pas normal
dans une démocratie comme la france
compte pour manifestent pacifiquement
pour beaucoup de manifestants la plupart
des gens qui ont perdu un oeil et c'est
pour la vie c'est pas seulement pour le
mouvement des idées jaune ou parce que
les malades n'a créé que les présidents
étaient pacifiques
ils étaient visés sciemment dans la tête
par la police dgpn a enterré quasiment
toutes les enquêtes
il ya eu plus de 2000 blessés certains
qui sont maintenant en incapacité à vie
qui sont handicapés à vie
il ya eu des gens qui ont perdu des
mains à cause de ces grenades de
désencerclement extrêmement dangereuse
la france cette équipe est massivement
barbe de guerre lanceurs de balles de
défense fusils mitrailleurs et grenades
gély f4 et c&a les a utilisé de manière
massive et de manière catastrophique
compte tenu du nombre de blessés moi
j'étais scandalisé de voir la façon dont
était maltraité les manifestants alors
on était toujours en miroir la violence
des casseurs
donc il fallait répondre et c'est faux
puisque encore une fois la plupart des
blessés étaient des manifestants
pacifiques
il ya des images terribles à bordeaux ce
manifestant gilet jaune qui s'en va qui
est de dos qui est visé dans la tête par
un groupe de policiers qui ensuite
conscients de ce qu'ils ont fait et
c'est dedans levé l'épreuve et de s'en
aller donc cette répression d'état a été
couverte en plus haut lieu par les
préfets mais aussi par emmanuel macron
qui rappelez vous donner des leçons à
geneviève le guen lorsqu'elle s'était
fait bousculer fracture du crâne par une
charge de police depuis jugé bien trop
violente lui disais quand on est fragile
on se met pas dans des situations comme
ça en allant dans des endroits où les
manifestations ne sont pas autorisés
voilà les paroles qui avait le chef de
l'état il ne voulait pas entendre les
mots de violences policières ou de
répression puisqu'on utilise pas ça dans
le cadre d'un état de droit
or c'est bien ce qui s'est passé donc on
peut se poser la question du fait de
savoir si ce ce régime ce moment de la
vème république macro nist est encore un
état de droit parce que ces deux ans de
répression violente ultraviolente
couverte par la hiérarchie policière et
par l'igpn sont une indignité une
indignité pour tout le pays pas
seulement pour ceux qui les ont
organisés mais aussi pour moi j'étais un
des rares en plateau à être scandalisé a
dénoncé ces violences a parlé des
barbares dans la police a parlé de la
façon dont cette violence était
inacceptable enfin on parle du vin qui
sont mutilés à vie pour avoir manifesté
pour des idées politiques
et personne dans la classe
journalistique autorisé n'avait l'air
plus choqué que ça situe juste bon bah
voilà c'est faut dire que j'ai des
jaunisses vont pas avec le dos de la
cuillère c'est encore une fois des
manifestants qui étaient pacifiques et
puis oui il ya de quoi être excité quand
on n'est jamais entendue et que et donc
à la répression a été ensuite ajoutée là
la couche le glaçage de communication
politique avec ce grand débat qui a
servi de campagne pour la république en
marche pour les européennes où emmanuel
macron a monopolisé la parole il l'a
volé à ceux qui la voulait justement et
tous les cahiers de doléances qui avait
été organisée par les maires avec les
gilet jaune dorment aujourd'hui dans les
caves de la bibliothèque nationale de
france ils n'ont pas été consultés n'ont
pas été ouverts et quand on a eu le
rendu de
c'est de cette consultation nationale on
a eu droit à une conférence de presse
des malades mâcon qui avait choisi
quelques thèmes pour dire c'est super
vous n'avez pas compris mais c'est pas
grave je continue la réforme des
retraites je vous ai pas entendu je m'en
fous et puis si vous recommencez eh ben
on vous privera l'autre oeil
c'est inacceptable ce moment que nous
vivons aujourd'hui dans la 5ème
politique je ne comprends pas qu'on
puisse le tolérer qu'il n'y ait pas une
opposition beaucoup plus farouches par
rapport au danger que représentait
malades macron pour nous tous mais selon
vous qu'est ce que ça révèle en fait
finalement cette défiance qui sait même
plus une défiance c'est presque des
conflits qu'on voit à chaque
manifestation qui qui s'instaure entre
les forces de l'ordre d'un côté et le
peuple français de l'autre comme s'il y
avait deux cantines qui s'affrontaient
qu'est ce que ça révèle de notre de
repli comment vous pouvez imaginer une
sorte de réconciliation entre ces deux
camps qui apparaissent la réconciliation
elle se fera par pas par humanisme il
faut un moment comprendre que derrière
l'uniforme il ya des êtres humains que
derrière gilet jaune ya des êtres
humains et qu'on ne traite pas comme ça
quand on est quand on est civilisés
quand on est humaniste quand on est à un
moment sont pas la guerre
cette bière d'ailleurs elle elle est la
preuve qu'on a quitté aussi le rib l'âge
de la lutte des classes d'une certaine
façon qui va vouloir rattacher les
wagons si on veut parler de politique de
maquereaux politique mais c'est des gens
qui sont tous dans le même bateau
les policiers sont extrêmement mal
traités alors ils sont mieux traités que
les autres puisqu'il arrive à avoir
peut-être la retraite plus tôt plus de
salaire et c est quand même ils ont des
conditions de travail extrêmement
difficile ils sont traités envoyer tous
les week-ends et cetera pour protéger
quelques-uns qui font les lois
d'insécurité les lois de casse globale
donc donc je ne comprends pas qu'ils
aient pas de davantage finalement
d'intelligence de deux classes en disant
mais on ne se parle pas pourquoi il n'y
a pas là quelque chose de l'ordre d'une
révolution citoyenne
si on compare les ca comme ça en disant
que oui si on veut parler du peuple
alors c'est le quentin connu il ya par
un peuple il ya des peuples mais il ya
quand même
la classe possédante les rentiers et la
classe de ceux qui n'ont rien et de
moins en moins et on voit bien que
mirage des trente glorieuses est en
train de se refermer et la classe
moyenne qui a pu croire un moment
appartenir à la classe supérieure coûte
trop cher etc ces deux mouvements dits
jaune c'est cette classe moyenne qui
sent venir la précarisation le
déclassement et pour soi et pour ses
enfants il y avait beaucoup de retraités
lors de ces manifestations qui étaient
là pour leurs enfants et leurs petits
enfants en disant c'est pas normal qu'on
en soit là et que moi j'ai voilà j'ai
parlé à des gens qui étaient là parce
que leurs enfants faisaient des études
ne trouvait pas de travail qu' il dise
c'est pas normal moi j'ai eu un boulot
chez lui la retraite à 60 ans et la
caisse que qu'est ce que vont avoir mes
enfants auxquels est là la politique et
elle se faisait dans la rue parce que
trop peu de deux parties sont maintenant
capables de faire de la politique de la
politique populaire donc les gilets
jaunes se sont organisés avec les
assemblées populaires avec la volonté du
riq avec aussi une vraie réflexion sur
la démocratie comment réinjecter de la
démocratie dans une démocratie
d'opérette qui est devenue une
ploutocratie une oligarchie où
quelques-uns c'est pas nouveau à maurice
thorez dénonçait les 300 familles lors
du front populaire les 300 familles
elles sont toujours là c'est pas
forcément les mêmes
mais c'est à peu près 300 fortune qui
effectivement sont la france décide de
qui va être le candidat qui va gagner
et puis ça suffit et puis après tout les
politiques sont faits en direction des
possédants et jamais jamais trop
rarement en direction de ceux qui n'ont
rien malgré ce qu'ils essayent de
défendre sur les plateaux de télé les
responsables de la majorité en tant qu
ils font des lois sociales formidable
qu'ils sont incompris donc je crois que
les inégalités explosent qu'il n'y a pas
de volonté de justice fiscale et que le
loin de d'essayer de rapprocher les
populations on les divise
et c'est la police qui fait le sale
boulot et qui ne comprend pas que ce
boulot là les desserts autant que que
ceux qui sont dans la rue et c'est
malheureux de
de voir ça mais je pense qu'il y aura
peut-être un changement générationnel
une prise de conscience déjà dans la
prise de conscience de deux systèmes de
crise permanente quel capitalisme qui
arrive quand même à un terme évident
cristal iter crise écologique crise
sociale crise économique permanente
donc pourquoi continuer dans un système
de crise permanente quand on est autant
de perdre en ait si peu de gagnant donc
il est important je pense de de relire
marx ou d'autres mais d'avoir une vision
historique de la politique pour
comprendre que le mouvement classique de
lutte des classes est bien présent
extrêmement présent et qu'on est en
train sous couvert de progressisme de
retourner au 19e siècle alors
vous évoquez le fait que la police fasse
justement le sale boulot et c'est vrai
qu'il convient de rappeler que tous les
ans on assista à 6000 voir à 7000
policiers qui sont blessés dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions et vous
évoquez également cette cassure qu'on a
pu assister qu'on a pu voir lors du
mouvement d'aidé gilet jaune et donc des
violences qui ont pu en découler
mais on voit également que dans la
société française les violences sont
contre la police mais également contre
les pompiers contre les professeurs
voire même contre des médecins ou des
infirmiers et donc il est difficile
d'imputer la seule responsabilité des
violences au comportement de certains
policiers
alors dès lors est ce que il n'y aurait
pas phénomène plus globale de refus de
l'autorité dans notre pays et finalement
est-ce qu'on n'assiste pas à une
délégitimation du pouvoir politique dans
notre pays
oui alors cette délégitimation elle et
elle est double elle est d'abord parce
que il y a un problème effectivement du
respect de l'autorité parce que toutes
les autorités ont été sapés à la base et
commençons par l'autorité du professeur
dans sa salle de classe
on a fait rentrer les parents d'élèves
on a essayé de dire que noter ce n'était
pas forcément bien on a appris les
preuves pour finalement pour d'aider des
gens qui étaient là pour assurer un
service mais pas pour éveiller des
futurs citoyens émancipé par le savoir
non on a traité les professeurs comme
des des responsables de garderies avec
le niveau scolaire qui a b c etc
donc oui déjà l'autorité première et
importante quand elle est nécessaire
elle doit être respectée pour ce qu'elle
vous apporte
or aujourd'hui on a deux les autorités
qui sont quand même assez caricaturale
avec une parole politique complètement
délégitimer ceux qui sont au pouvoir
mentent mais il manque maintenant de
manière extrêmement vulgaire c'est assez
obscènes de les voir mentir d'ailleurs
dans cette crise du coronavirus
rappelons le ne serait-ce que le sketch
des masques les masques c'était
totalement bidon ça servait à rien s'ils
battent ndiaye rigoler en plateau la
porte parole du gouvernement de ramener
n'importe quoi des masques tout ça parce
qu'on en avait pas et dès qu'on en a
faut mettre le mal partout tout le temps
dehors
on est le seul pays à avoir le masque
h24 quasiment dehors tout le temps y
compris les enfants de 6 ans donc
comment voulez vous croire la parole du
politique quand
est à ce point vide de tout sens elle
n'est que mensonges et manipulations et
communication propagande donc aucune
raison de croire à l'autorité politique
et puis de les autres autorités comme je
le disais elles ont été appelés dans
leurs pratiques de l'autorité ce qui
fait que oui c'est compliqué de
travailler sur cette base là et mais je
crois que les médecins sont encore
respectée même si on a vu les
scientifiques se crêper le chignon
on sait très bien le travail des
soignants était extrêmement respectée
pour ce qu'ils ont fait c'est pareil
pour les pompiers
même s'il ya eu un procès là pour viol
collectif physique quand même il ya
aussi quelques éléments un peu foireux
chez les pompiers il faudrait nettoyer
d'institutions comme celle là la police
est aussi majoritairement respecte et je
pense par la population malgré ce qu'on
a vu les gens conscients que la plupart
des policiers font un travail exemplaire
et un travail difficile je le redis
encore une fois qui est qui est
justement de se coltiner à la violence
de manière quotidienne
rappelons le nombre de suicides dans la
police je crois que gérald darmanin de
l'emploi de mots particulier sur ce
malaise dans la police pas plus que
christophe castaner pas plus que les
autres donc la violence est partout le
non respect des autorités
il est partout mais il faudrait que les
autorités pour être respectée soit
exemplaire qu'elle apporte quelque chose
comme le professeur dans sa classe qui
apporte le savoir or aujourd'hui les
autorités elles sont au pire ridicule au
mieux sans incidence sur la vie de tous
les jours et et on voit bien qu'on est
dans une resucée d'ancien régime quand
vous avez eu la sphère des homards de
françois de rugy
le pauvre françois de rugy qui ne
comprenaient pas ce qu'on l'ait de ce
qu'on me reprocher puisque l'une avait
mangé que ce qu'on lui proposait à la
cantine
enfin par la cantine mais en tant que
grand chambellan de l'assemblée ils
avaient le droit à être traité comme un
prince enfin il y a qu'en france que les
ministres et les uns et les autres sont
traités comme comme des nobles de louis
xiv dans les autres pays européens quand
vous êtes politique c'est un sale boulot
vous n'êtes pas forcément mais traiter
que les autres merkel fait ses courses
au supermarché du coin et moi je veux
c'est justement pour les anglais à
l'ambassade de grande bretagne
j'ai les les anglais les ministres
anglais qui passe et voir leur leurs
homologues français comprenaient pas
qu'est ce qu'il ya dans votre pays
pourquoi les politiques ils sont aussi
bronzée ils sont tout le temps maquis
etc ils font du cinéma c'est quoi et ça
quand vous voyez tony blair qui était
blanc comme un linge et chirac étaient
grands tout bronzé avec villepin tous
pareils on se dit oui ils font pas le
même métier
donc à un moment qu'est-ce qu'on veut
aussi que l exemplarité on attend de
ceux qui sont l'autorité qui incarne
l'autorité quand ils nous jouent une
mauvaise opérette de 1787 très bien vous
avez évoqué un petit peu la crise du coc
vide
c'est vrai qu'on a on a beaucoup abordé
jusqu'ici les violences policières les
manifestations et gilets jaunes
l'article 24 lalo sécurité globale mais
on a aussi cette crise que nous vivons
depuis bientôt un an
est ce que pour vous c'est un prétexte
idéal pour rogner de nombreuses libertés
fondamentales et ensuite comment jugez
vous la réaction des français face à ces
mesures radicales
est ce que vous pensez qu'elle est trop
froide est ce que vous pensez que les
français ne ne réagissent pas assez à
ses libertés fondamentales qui nous sont
peu à peu retirée qui nous sont retirés
pour un temps indéterminé à chaque fois
oui on a un peu l'impression d'une
expérience de milgram géante à voir
jusqu'où on peut plus et l'acceptation
des populations vers des mesures
liberticides et totalement loufoque
moi j'ai pas compris quand on a accepté
que les commerces fermés puis que les
problèmes des produits de 2 qui
n'étaient pas des essentiels devait
aussi être non accessibles dans les
supermarchés dont confirmait des rayons
entiers
vous ne pourrez pas acheter de
chaussettes si votre enfant a plus de 18
mois
comment pouvait-on accepter une chose
pareille mais on l'a accepté
mais il ya des commerçants qui en sont
membres qui vont mourir qui vont fermer
boutiques et comment on peut accepter
aussi d'être traités de cette façon là
comme des enfants avec une application
bidon qui a coûté des millions aux
contribuables qui ne sert à rien ce top
cow vide qu'il faudra télécharger parce
que c'est bien
mais c'est scandaleux cette gestion de
crise en fait à montrer à la fois la
nullité du personnel politique qui n'est
pas fait en fait pour gérer un pays qui
est là pour simplement gérer des
dérégulations des lois qui vont être
bénéfiques aux à la finance
internationale
mais quand vous avez besoin de quelqu'un
qui est là pour défendre un pays pour
défendre ses citoyens il ya plus
personne
ces gens là ne pensent qu'à leur
carrière personnelle leur reconversion
dans le privé au sein des lobbies qui
les ont mis à leur place et c'est bien
tout le problème c'est qu'on n'a plus le
personnel politique qui faudrait en fait
pour ces temps difficiles de crise
perpétuelle et où il faut taper sur la
table il faut arrêter la folie dans
laquelle on nous installe or cette folie
là qui a été assumée par le politique
avec des ordres contradictoires toutes
les semaines avec ces histoires de
confinement déconfinement totalement
ratée avec ces dates qu'on nous donne
les la façon dont on parle aux gens un
président de la république qui est là à
rappeler les gestes barrière lord
adresse à la nation à un conseil de
défense pour savoir si on va pouvoir
acheter des sapins de noël à noël et
tout ça qui pour moi est à la fois fou
ridicule et inacceptable qui a été
acceptée par les français dans une
apathie inquiétante toujours le problème
de la majorité silencieuse ou bien on
est très peu finalement à se rendre
compte de la supercherie et je dis pas
que le virus n'existe pas le virus
existent il a extrêmement virulent il
est extrêmement dangereux pour certaines
catégories de personnes pour beaucoup
d'autres c'est un virus qui qui ne
conduit pas à la mort qui affaiblit
certes mais encore une fois on a flingué
l'économie on a essayé de voir comment
pouvait contrôler les populations les a
empêchés de sortir de chez elle on les a
on a mis en prison des populations
entières pour cette ce fameux virus qui
n'est pas si mortel alors oui ils tuent
et ne m'aimait bien moins que d'autres
alors est ce que c'est une répétition
générale avant un autre virus qui va
arriver qui sera bien plus terrible est
ce que c'est pour nous habituer à ne
plus jamais sortir à ne plus jamais
faire la fête à télétravailler être
encore plus atomisé
donc la surveillance totale ou est ce
que c'est pour voir l'acceptation des
populations à des mesures liberticides
et jusqu'où on va pouvoir pousser ces
règles là c'est scandaleux c'est
proprement scandaleux cette gestion
sanitaire en europe particulièrement a
été a été lamentable en france pire
qu'ailleurs parce qu'on a les pires
chiffres 1 contrairement à ce que dit
jean castex avec des chiffres en plus
qui viennent des autorités de santé qui
sont plus que discutables à la fois sur
les taux de mortalité mais aussi sur la
façon dont ont été ce fait les
dépistages les en fait les chiffres
gonflés dégonfle à la demande finalement
de ce qu'il faut faire dans quel faux
dégonfler parce qu'à noël et puis après
noël on va regonfler pour dire qu'il
faut peut-être rester encore un peu chez
soi comment on pique encore une fois
comment on peut y croire c'est quelque
chose qui rend là et quand vous êtes
raisonnable et que vous dites mais
attendez c'est quand même n'importe quoi
ce qui se passe vous êtes montrés du
doigt comme étant un complotiste parce
qu'ils organisent cette folie générale
et personnes devaient redescendre d'un
cran c'est à dire que là on va nous
proposer des vaccins avec une
technologie qui n'a jamais été utilisée
sur l'homme qui n'ont au dessus qui ont
été accélérés pour pourra être mis sur
le marché le plus rapidement possible la
rn messager et on applaudit des deux
bras en disant c'est génial cc
nobélisable la science avance c'est
super mais on n'a pas le retour de ce
que ça va faire dans plusieurs
générations ou bien quand on m'a vacciné
des millions de personnes plutôt que les
trente mille volontaires qui sont pris
le produit dans le bras et quand on
entend aujourd'hui on n'a aucune données
médicales sur ses vaccins puisque les
études médicales n'ont pas été publiés
c'est uniquement par conférence de
presse communiqué de presse que les
grands labos communiquer sur leurs
vaccins pour faire gonfler bien entendu
les actions de la bourse
et pourtant les autorités de santé vont
autoriser cénac saint saëns ans sans
même se poser la question de la réalité
de l'efficacité de ces vaccins
puisque un patron de labo disais que
aujourd'hui il n'y avait pas de
certitude sur le fait que le vaccin
allez pouvoir stopper la contamination
si vous êtes vacciné vous êtes toujours
contaminants donc à quoi sert le vaccin
alors il ya ça sert à avoir une forme
atténuée du virus ce qui est déjà le cas
pour de nombreux un symptôme atiku de
gens qui ont plus de manière atténuée
certes c'est max elles sont inefficaces
aujourd'hui on n'a pas la réponse on va
simplement des labos qui affirment que
leurs deux vaccins sont super efficace
avec des gens qui gèrent des autorités
de santé qui en août a plein de qualités
qui vont les mettre sur le marché mais
l'autorité de santé encore une fois
c'est elle qui en europe a poussé pour
qu'on utilise leur md et vire qui est
aujourd'hui un médicament jugé dangereux
dans le traitement du cobp ide et tout
ça parce que gilead a fait un lobbying
intensif
il faut savoir que entre juillet et
novembre octobre la commissaire
européenne à la santé a eu un rendez
vous téléphonique par mois avec gilead
en one to one
on sait pas ce qui s'est dit c'est sur
son carnet de rendez vous donc quand on
a ce lobbying des labos auprès de
décideurs qui ne sont même pas élu un
commissaire européen n'a aucun souffre
âge pour être là où il est on peut se
poser la question de comment nous
gouvernent de qu'est ce qu'on nous
demande de faire pourquoi on a pas de
transparence et encore une fois que fait
manuel macro et jouer au bonneteau
il parle d'un comité qui veulent assurer
la transparence de la vaccination et des
vaccins comité qu'il va créer avec un
casting dont on ne sait d'où une sorte
non y'a un truc qui s'appelle
l'assemblée nationale il ya un truc qui
s'appelle le droit à avoir accès aux
documents administratifs demande non si
on était dans une démocratie
fonctionnelle demandons à avoir accès
aux contrats qui sont passés entre les
laboratoires et les autorités qu'est ce
qu'il y a lancé contre un et puis et
puis demander des contre-expertises
puisque on peut se poser des questions
sur les compétences des autorités de
santé quand elle met sur le marché un
même désir qui vendu par gilead à
l'époque milatz avec ce médicament ne
servent à rien et il coûtait beaucoup
trop cher par rapport à ce qu'il était
encore une fois quelques lanceurs
d'alert l'avait dit on riait on leur
grille et revenez comme on s'est foutu
de la gueule de beaucoup de défenseurs
de l'hydroxyde chloroquine en disant que
ça ne fonctionnait pas et c'est parce
qu'on a arrêté les études pour bien
prouver que ça ne fonctionnait pas
jamais de ça fonctionnait ça s'en
remettaient les labos donc ce jeu de
lobbying intensif ou le ou finalement le
pouvoir démocratique n'existe plus moi
me pose question et l'apathie de mes
concitoyens me pose question aussi je ne
trouve pas normal qu'on accepte comme ce
qu'on nous impose aujourd'hui c'est
totalement inacceptable
quand les grandes surfaces
mais quand les commerçants fermaient je
n'ai pas compris que les gens
vieillissent finalement on est bien
élevé
on obéit en pensant faire la bonne chose
parfois je crois que c'est la résistance
parfois alors évidemment on n'est pas on
n'est pas en période de guerre ou quoi
que ce soit mais c'est la désobéissance
civile c'est aussi un moment de faire
marcher sa tête et se rendre compte
qu'il ya un truc qui cloche
et là il ya clairement un truc qui
cloche merci vous parliez du fameux
conseil de défense qui a été de
nombreuses fois critiqué pour un manque
de transparence finalement défendu par
d'autres comme une façon de gérer la
crise mais ce que finalement si on peut
débattre sur les questions de fond il ya
l'autoritarisme car peut-être défendue
par les citoyens mais est-ce qu'on peut
pas voir également un problème lié à la
forme et à la façon de gouverner de ce
nouveau monde comme cela fut dénoncée
par de nombreux corps intermédiaires
finalement ce soit l'amateurisme assumer
la république en marche
ou alors les nouvelles méthodes issues
du monde de l'entreprise est ce que tout
cela vient pas finalement percuter et
bouleverser les méthodes de gouvernement
et de concertation politique
traditionnelle de l'ancien monde alors
il y a encore une fois je parlais de
paranoïa
clairement on pratique bouquet risée
paranoïaque du pouvoir le conseil de
défense permet de mettre sous le sceau
du secret défense tout ce qui s'est dit
dans ces conseils de défense donc quand
la justice va perdre son travail et
enquêter sur ce moment de folie qui
s'est emparée de nos sociétés pour dire
mais qu'est ce qu'ils en font pourquoi
ils ont fait ça et bien tous corps a dit
emmanuel macron son premier ministre et
les autres sera placée sous le sceau du
secret défense donc les juges n'y ont
pas accès donc ça permettra d'éviter la
justice pour ces gens là puisque une
grande partie de ce qui est décidé par
si ces gens là au pouvoir c'est d'éviter
d'être responsable s'est désengagé leurs
responsabilités et dire j'ai fait tout
ce qu'il fallait pour ne pas devant la
justice quand elle arrivera est
responsable 80% de l'énergie politique
des politiques en place est elle liée à
le désengagement de leurs
responsabilités et les 20% restants
étaient à la communication publique pour
faire part qu'ils étaient des capitaines
de vaisseau courageux dans la tempête
non ils étaient juste totalement largué
ils savaient pas ce qu'ils faisaient ils
ont fait à peu près n'importe
ouais donc en faisant n'importe quoi il
assurait une déresponsabilisation en
disant c'est vous les français qui fait
n'importe quoi qui est responsable
mais oui mais c'est eux les
scientifiques qui m'ont dit qu'il
fallait pas mettre le masque à l'époque
c'est pas moi moi je ne savais pas c'est
vraiment heureux donc donc qu'à un
moment quand on cherche à être élu quand
on cherche à être ministre quand on
cherche à les présidents marne est
responsable on accepte cette
responsabilité et on accepte oui de
faire des choix difficiles et de les
assumer
le conseil de défense c'est simplement
encore une fois ne pas assumer sa
responsabilité celle d'être le président
d'un pays c'est d'éviter la transparence
et d'éviter la responsabilité c'est
encore une fois inacceptable dans une
démocratie qui fonctionne on doit rendre
des comptes
emmanuel macron a été élu il ne rend
plus de compte et il faudra attendre
comme jeudi le travail de la justice qui
sera dans longtemps qu'il sera
extrêmement long on regarde et on ya un
président en ce moment qui est devant
les juges nicolas sarkozy il a fallu des
années pour réouvrir les dossiers de
financement libyen mais aussi d'autres
dossiers d'association de malfaiteurs
qu'il a pu faire avec les siens à des
fins de financement de campagne et le
simple fait d'être présent dans la pluie
l'immunité fait que c'est très long et
là emmanuel macron en rajoute une couche
avec le secret défense et l'assurance de
ne pas rendre de comptes
quand il ne sera plus président et qu'il
faudra qu'il réponde de ce moment de
folie qu'il nous a imposé et ça je
trouve que c'est grave
encore une fois c'est inacceptable dans
une démocratie fonctionnelle mais
visiblement la france les français
s'accommode de cette fausse démocratie
où on les traite comme des enfants et où
les maltraitent surtout comme des
enfants maltraités
alors
guise de mot de la fin pour avoir une
approche un peu plus globale des forces
politiques qui sont en jeu actuellement
en france tout d'abord je vais vous
demander comment qualifieriez-vous
emmanuel macron sur un spectre politique
libérale autoritaire socialiste et
pourquoi
et ensuite comment vous voyez des
perspectives d'apaisement est ce que
vous arrivez à imaginer une force
politique capable de réconcilier les
français notamment pour l'échéance de
et est-ce qu'on se dirige peut-être vers
une nouvelle confrontation un peu
caricatural entrain macron d'un côté un
le pen de l'autre entre les mondialistes
et nationaliste est ce qu'on va avoir à
nouveau cette opposition ou doit-il y
avoir un retour du clivage gauche droite
afin d'éviter le flou entretient
volontairement emmanuel macron je crois
qu emmanuel macron d'entretien pulse
loup il est il est un président de
droite autoritaire et réactionnaire même
s'il a fait quelques lois sociétal pour
pour donner des gages sur sa gauche mais
aujourd'hui moi je ne comprends pas ce
qu'ils issus du ps sont dans cette
majorité sans se poser de questions
puisque la dérive ou le fait qu'ils
menaient macron être assumé son virage
réactionnaire est total et donc c'est
clair il a il est alors il est à
l'instant où je parle
cette personne là mais il est surtout un
formidable opportuniste c'est à dire
qu'il va changer de costume en fonction
de la température de l'opinion publique
il est là pour surfer sur les tendances
qui vont lui permettre de donner des
gages suffisants pour compter les points
et se retrouve effectivement au deuxième
tour ou reprendre quelques points dans
les sondages mais et c'est là où il est
dangereux parce qu'il n'a aucune colonne
idéologique si ce n'est celle du
mondialisme et de l'école de chicago
mais à part ça politiquement il est
nulle part et c'est bien le danger de ce
président caméléon qui est capable du
pire comme on l'a vu pour ce qui est de
rassembler les français c'est
extrêmement compliqué puisque le pays
est divisé
il l'a toujours été mais c'est devenu
invisible les gilets jaunes ont quand
même mis sur la table ses divisions
entre les zones désertées péri urbaines
rurales et les villes c'est le cas des
votes encore aujourd'hui de la façon
dont on envisage l'écologie pour
certains elle et punitive pour d'autres
c'est normal c'est c'est tout le
problème en fait de trouver qu'est-ce
qui pourrait aujourd'hui rassembler les
français
je crois qu'il ya une chose qui les
rassemble c'est la défense de leurs
intérêts et la défense quand même du
pays de ce qu'est l'idéal français donc
il y aura je pense pour 2022 un pôle
souverainiste important on reparle de
2005 de ce référendum volé on se pose la
question de l'utilité de l'europe qui a
été finalement totalement inutile dans
la crise du coc vide incapable de gérer
les frontières incapable de gérer les
protocoles sanitaires d'un pays à
l'autre
qui est qui a fait de la communication
voilà et puis qui est maintenant et
c'est important de le dénoncer
la commission est simplement un outil ou
les lobbys vont faire leur shopping quoi
en fait moi des lois acheter mes
médicaments fait un truc sans aucun
contrôle démocratique donc c'est
extrêmement grave donc
donc oui il ya cette question là je
pense qu'il ya la question de l'avenir
quel avenir voulons-nous pour les plus
jeunes pour nos enfants
dans cette dans ce monde où la chine est
en train de gagner
finalement le modèle chinois s'exporte
très bien un modèle de surveillance
globale modèle de répression modèle de
libéralisme autoritaire
est-ce qu'on veut d'un libéralisme
autoritaire ou pas pas forcément
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
rêvent un peu d'apaisement qui rêvent de
de pouvoir vivre tranquillement sans
chercher à toujours gagner plus
consommer plus donc il ya la question
écologique qui va être clé aussi dans
dans une certaines plates formes de
rassemblement qui pourrait être là et
c'est ce que c'est ce qui est difficile
finalement à faire émerger puisque il
faut il faut arriver à faire que tout ça
fonctionne tout
défendant les intérêts d'un pays mais un
pays seul ne peut rien et donc il faut
arriver aussi à ce que le moment soit
mondiale à ce que cette prise de
conscience soit mondiale et que donc on
en finisse avec ce système de la crise
permanente et qu'on arrive à redonner de
la stabilité de l'espoir une question
importante que celle de la monnaie
aussi comment on décide de refonder la
monnaie du pouvoir d'achat bien entendu
le panier de la ménagère le fameux
padena ménagères c'est n'importe quoi en
fait un pour parler du pouvoir d'achat
dès français en réalité tous les
produits essentiels eux augmentent le
logement est devenu inaccessible le plus
la plupart des français aucune réflexion
sans d'aidé des pouvoirs en place sur le
logement
très peu alors que c'est la clé pour une
société apaisée mais c'est de pouvoir se
loger correctement sans que plus de la
moitié des ressources il passe donc
beaucoup beaucoup de chantiers mais je
pense qu'il ya quelques grands axes qui
peuvent rassembler les français
merci monsieur poulat pour cet entretien
passionnant
merci pour la force de vos convictions
et nous espérons vivement que ces
échanges auront permis à chacun de
réfléchir sur l'état de notre société
d'alimenter le débat est aussi la
réflexion de chacun
en effet avoir son propre avis selon
forget débattre et échanger c'est le
sens même de notre think tank scopeo
l'observatoire politique et nous
espérons vous retrouver prochainement
pour de nouveaux entretiens
merci avance les repreneurs si je vous
remercie monsieur poulat merci à vous
st
tant mieux